we have sh Aon here with r you
going I hope I'm going cuz I need y'all
to come with me because I can't go by
myself at this point but hey everyone
before we get started I want to draw
your attention to the bottom left side
of the screen so if you have any
questions whatsoever make sure you click
that link and also if you want to
connect with me during at any point you
can find my information on LinkedIn so
let's get into
it they got me using a Mac and I'm not a
Mac person y'all just that why so I'm
Sher and I want you to consider me as
your personal GPS that's gentle push
system for the next 15 to 20 minutes
we're going to get prepared for a
journey that you may or may not have
been planning I know I know you did not
come to this session to learn about work
of a travel guide or to map out a trip
or even worse a hyp pathetical trip but
trust me by the time you leave here
you'll be telling everyone that you need
a new GPS system and that's a gentle
push
system Mac work there we
go every day we're losing data
scientists and not because people are
not excited but because they start
learning and then become stuck or they
get lost without Direction they do not
have the confidence support or resources
to keep
going activist Maran wght elderman
stated you can't be what you can't see
and this resonated with with me early in
my data science career because I didn't
see many people who look like me people
of color or women who could uh give me
that comfort of going to ask them
questions getting um information about
their experience or just being a mentor
to me as mentioned earlier in today's
session by keynote David
Messa so let me tell you a little bit
about myself I'm Sher the director of
workshops for the carpentries and that
was my introduction to r i was Data
curious but didn't quite know where to
go from there I hadn't mapped out my
journey I was not following the GPS the
original one or the one we learned about
earlier today I'm a city girl from
Detroit and when I was deciding where to
go to college initially I thought I
wanted to go to a HBCU that's a
historically black college where there
was a shopping mall on every corner and
not an entire State
over but needless to say I attended
Michigan Technological University and it
was the total opposite I received my
Bachelor's in Business Administration
Management and marketing and then I left
one Peninsula to go to a totally
different Peninsula and that's Miami
Florida um to obtain my master's degree
in Hospitality management where I
thought I wanted to run hotels only to
discover that I only like staying in
them needless to say I never saw
directions leading to a career in data
science I had no idea that I would land
my dream job with the carpentries after
only applying three times for a position
okay Shear you have your dream job what
does that have to do with anything I'm
so glad you asked so let the journey
begin but I have one question for for
are you are you
going so I don't know about you but when
someone ask me are you going I generally
have a plethora of questions to ask them
where are we going how are we going to
get there how long is it going to take
who's going and what do I need to bring
and we all know that we can get a
variety of questions from this a variety
of answers from this question and
that'll dictate how we respond and if
we'll respond favorably or not well as
your GPS that's gentle push system I
want to ask you this question and give
you a few perspectives that will
hopefully encourage you to say yes so
here's the first ask are you
going Sher I don't know where we're
going and I know so I'm so glad you said
that well it's okay for us not to know
exactly where we're going have you ever
gotten in the car
and you just drove not knowing where you
were going to head where you were headed
but ended up in a pretty good Final
Destination think about a GPS even if
you have the final exact destination
when you plug it in you have no idea
where you're going you just follow the
instructions the world the roads may be
unfamiliar to you the highways are
familiar but you just drive and you get
there when you're joining a new
community such as data science it can be
very similar Maybe you are starting your
first career or you are switching
careers you're terrified because you
don't know where you're going you not
sure what lies ahead and this was me
when I entered into this field at the
time I was in between jobs and we know
what that means I was working odd and
end jobs but nothing that I wanted to
pursue permanently or anything that was
stable until someone someone in this
room shared with me an opportunity about
working with the carpentries now
remember y'all saw my background was in
business management and marketing and
somewhat Hospitality management and I
googled this organization and I was like
um what can I do in this techie Cody
like for real organization and y'all let
me tell y'all a secret in high school I
skipped the class for coding I never
went so I knew this wasn't the job for
me but needless to say I did apply for
Workshop administrator and I got the job
and let me tell you I definitely thought
that my GPS was supposed to reroute me
or start all over because I did not feel
like I belong mostly everyone on the
team had doctor degrees and things like
oceanography mechanical engineering
physiology uh
bioinformatics come on now and so you
see I definitely felt like I was driving
down the wrong lane and waiting for
further instructions to getting back on
track with this business and Hospitality
degree your girl had extreme impostor
syndrome I mean I really didn't think
that I I was good enough I didn't know
if I had the right background I felt
like I wasn't worthy to be on the team
and sometimes I question myself like how
did I really get this job did they
really hire the right person and I would
go to meetings and I would rarely speak
and as you can see that's kind of huge
for an extrovert like myself
I was afraid to say something that was
stupid or something that wouldn't make
sense or that would make me stand out in
the crowd to make it seem as though I
wasn't supposed to be there I had no
idea where I was going and how I fit in
on this team but once I was on the team
I did gain a few GPS's and that's gentle
push system who assured me that I was
doing well encouraged me to take on
additional responsibility and it was
because of those conversations that I
was able to try things on the team such
as help support our first international
con uh conference which was easy because
I had years of experience doing that
however leading a technical project not
so much I gained so much experience
learning how to share my vision with
someone who I didn't know understood my
jargon or me trying to talk to them in
their jargon I had I had have I not had
I not listened to this GPS I may may
still be a workshop administrator I
didn't know where my trajectory would
lead me but I'm glad I went and it was
okay that I didn't know where I was
going now so I got to ask you again are
you
going sh I don't know but if I did how
would I get there so another great
question I'm glad you asked so let's go
back to that GPS the original one and
not the one we just learned about
earlier so when you put in a destination
have you ever noticed that there are
options for you various ways for you to
get to your destination by car by bus by
walking a shared rides or sometimes even
a boat and sometimes it may require you
to do a mixture of both depending on
where your beginning destination is
compared to where you want to end and
the same can be true in our personal
lives we can have a goal in mind an
outcome a set intention and once we
begin planning the pth pathway we
discover that there can be various ways
for us to
continue do you remember your early
introduction into programming were you
overwhelmed how did you decide which
language you were going to use did you
start with one language and then switch
to another maybe you started with a
proprietary language and then switched
to an open source language which we
heard a question about earlier maybe you
started with python then switched to R
well let me tell you as I started with
with the carpentries initially I thought
I was just going to come in and do some
data entry and bounce well no however as
I started to you know really immerse
myself I wanted to understand the tools
that were being offered and so I started
to explore various ways I could grow in
the company and started thinking about
how I could use the tools of my everyday
work I was totally surprised to see that
I could use it for both my personal life
and my professional life and remind me
to tell you a story about how one of our
co-workers used it to help plan her wedd
use GitHub to plan her
wedding now I wanted to be able to
recommend Solutions and ideas with
metrics behind it but the thing was I
would have to ask someone to get me the
data and half the time I didn't know
what I really wanted I didn't know what
to ask for I didn't know how I wanted
the data to look when it came to me and
so I felt like I was being indecisive
and I didn't want to ask them because I
didn't want to waste their time so let
me tell you I was kind of intimidated
and this led me to decide okay sh Erin
you got to figure this out you need to
figure out which language you're going
to use so my super my supervisor gave me
a few tasks to use with python and it
seemed to be okay but I wasn't really
mesing well with it and so then another
supervisor gave me a few things and
introduced me to R to try to do a couple
of tasks with that one and I was like
okay I think when this might work a
little bit better and I discovered along
the way way that R was more suitable for
my
lifestyle now I understood the logic
just a little bit more than python but
not a whole lot but enough for me to say
okay this is the language I want to
focus on and so then I began taking
beginner courses with r and trying to
identify different tasks that I could
use daily to help me use R so I was
ecstatic and amazed at how much simpler
decision making had become just by using
these just by using this package now
that I had the tools to help me I was no
longer guessing or developing theories
to recommend future endeavors for the
carries workshops but had some data to
back it
up okay Shar nice story but what does
this really have to do with getting
around I know I know now remember I said
with GPS depending on your destination
you may have to take different models of
Transportation so sometimes you may have
to take a couple of waves of getting
there
so as an early adopter somewhat not
really in my career of data science I
eventually discovered that I wanted to
use coding to help me make decisions but
again remember I didn't know how to get
there so first I tried to use someone
else's knowledge hoping they would get
me there that's considered shared a
shared ride Uber right however I noticed
that I was not that was not the best
option for me so I said okay let me try
it myself so I rolled a bike a little
bit Switching gears it caused me to have
to do some research that's when I was
you know Switching gears and then I even
got on the bus a few times I had to do a
couple of transfers that was me trying R
and then python you know and SQL and
none of those worked for me either but
then once I figured out that R was the
one for me I was able to get a bit more
advanced and then I was able to drive to
my destination which was ultimately to
be able to develop the code to provide
data and metrics to help forecast um and
predict different trends so even though
I had to try a few different vehicles I
did get to my destination now I've given
you a few reasons why you should say yes
to going so I have to ask you one more
time because we know third time's always
a charm so are you
going now maybe you're just a little
apprehensive or a little concerned that
don't that you don't have everything you
need to get there or maybe you're
thinking you know what I want to go
share I really do but I need just a
little bit of a push or tug or just a
little bit of help no worries cuz guess
what I told you I am your GPS that's
your gentle push system so which means
that I'm going to give you the I'm going
to nudge you and give you the guide that
you need to help you get to where you
need to go so there have been many times
when using the GPS that's the original
one when you maybe if just the GPS went
offline and now all of a sudden you're
like it's not working properly and tell
me at that point what did you do did you
just say oh forget it did you throw your
phone in frustration or maybe you just
said you know what forget it I'm not
going I'mma stay put or maybe you said
you know what let me just ask for some
help or see what other programs are
available maybe you didn't use the Apple
version which I don't know what an apple
map is but maybe you use Wes or the
Google Maps so or maybe you said you
know what let me ask for let me ask for
help and ask for exact exact directions
or maybe you ask for alternative
solution either way you did not just
stop along on your journey or you didn't
stop along your journey of trying to get
to your destination you asked for help
to keep
going so I realized I've been talking a
little bit and haven't really told you
about the carpentries and so let me tell
you a little about the carpentries and
what we do and what I do the carpentries
is a nonprofit organization ation we
teach Nava scientists and researchers
how to analyze data using open software
such as R python get SQL Unix shell just
the name a few and we've trained over
4,400 uh volunteer instructors to teach
comprehensive live coding workshops all
over the world and to date we've
organized over 4,100 workshops both in
person and virtually reaching nearly
98,000
Learners now
I'd like to consider us a GPS that's a
gentle push system to anyone who was
thinking about data science is new to
the field switching fields or even just
want to explore something new all of our
curriculum it's designed for you to be
able to self te yourself however going
to a workshop will allow you to get that
guidance and get questions answered in
real time many of the testimonials we've
heard over the years was I didn't know
this existed I wish I would have known
about this during my PhD program your
resources has helped me as I was
starting my new career in data science
and I even met someone today and was
just like man I just really wish I knew
about this in my career and that's
always refreshing and so if you are
someone um who feels as though that you
felt like that or you're still needing
that extra push as your GPS this is my
Shameless plug to tell you you need to
sign up for car trees workshops and no
worries I'll make sure you do and there
may be a car instructor somewhere in the
room or someone I I see see so y'all
don't even have to come to me you can
see anyone in the room about signing up
for a carpentries
workshop so as you continue about your
final destination and where you're going
I want you to remember that you do not
have to travel alone for me had it not
been for co-workers who were pulling who
were willing to be my GPS that's gentle
push system and have many our sessions
with me or organizations like the POS
who offered a two-month introduction to
the FTI verse last year I could not I
would still be sitting around asking
myself am I going today after six years
of being introduced to this field I
would somewhat consider myself a data
scientist I've use my GPS system to help
me understand the direction and path
that I want to take in the digital world
well mostly but with their help I was
able to go from a part-time Workshop
administrator to Workshop manager to
director dep director of workshops to
now director of workshops of a team that
initially I knew nothing about however
it didn't happen until I was able to
answer yes to the question are you going
even when I didn't know where I was
going even when I had to try different
ways of getting to that Final
Destination and even when I had to ask
for
help now there may be some a few of you
in here who have said you know what Shar
I figured it out and I've already
arrived and that is amazing so you may
not need to be a GP you may not need a
GPS but guess what that means you could
be a GPS and please know that the
carpentries is a place for you and if
you have an interest in becoming an
instructor a trainer a lesson developer
a lesson maintainment or even have
expertise and would like to share your
expertise with our community then guess
what the carpentries welcome you and as
your GPS of this system of this session
I encourage you to scan this barcode and
you can learn about various ways to get
involved with the carpentries and become
your very own
GPS your journey may not look like the
one you originally mapped out mine sure
didn't but there may have been a few
certain uncertainties along the way
however you will never get there unless
you take that first
step Kirsten Hubbert stated you can't
control the past but you can control
where you go next so now that you have
been given a GPS to encourage you to say
yes along your journey all I need you to
do is just go however you decide to get
there or whatever method you decide to
take I ask you to take a step in that
direction and with that I have one more
question to ask you are you going thank
you